I've just watched episode two of strange
new worlds and at Astra per Aspira is a
much better episode than the first
episode much more interesting I do like
the Star Trek Court episodes
small problem
the end didn't make any sense and it's
the big problem with Star Trek doing
prequels
[Music]
okay so obviously we know if you're a
Trekkie
that we've explored this augmented
person thing before
Dr Bashir was genetically engineered and
they did a whole episode about that that
because of the violence
Etc it's following Khan and his war and
genetically engineered humans trying to
take over
genetically engineered augmented people
within the Federation is illegal
now a lot of this episode tries to argue
that actually genetic engineering is
okay and I'm like
I think that's a flawed argument to
begin with but then the augment it
basically shifts and they basically say
look she it's not her fault she was
augmented she never asked for it so you
know that makes it okay and genetic
engineering is a nuanced argument I
agree with that because in some ways
it's great you can you can genetically
engineer away many illnesses but in
other ways it's dangerous when do you
start genetical engineering because you
prefer your child to have blue eyes and
things like this it goes complicated
but in this episode
they were a bit stuck
they wanted to do this episode and you
can argue that okay yes it's about
augmented but they're really talking
about
any persecuted person racism sexism the
transgender argument any any
persecuted people within our society
that's what they're trying to talk about
and and I think the way number one spoke
about her persecution was actually
incredibly powerful and something we
should all
listen to
but on a technical point
because this episode couldn't actually
resolve
the genetic engineering issue because it
follows up in other episodes later in
the timeline they had to come up with
this
twist
now in the episode has been oh so clever
the solicitors the law has been so
clever they got her and they allowed the
judges to confirm that she was granted
Asylum
and they said technically she requested
it now
when you request Asylum you actually
have to say the words I request Asylum
for one which he didn't do but she says
oh she implied it so then they were able
to Grant it okay fine
why
would her being granted Asylum allow her
to continue being a Starfleet officer
it would allow her to continue being
part of the Federation and a federation
citizen but the laws were very specific
that you cannot join Starfleet if you're
an augment at the start of the episode
they were willing to let her be
dishonorably discharged because she lied
on the forms
Etc which again
is illegal it would be like joining the
Army here and lying on your form it's a
big deal okay
um saying you have some sort of medical
conditions around lying about it you
know what that sort of thing it's a big
deal
but why
so so they were willing to give her
um to stay within Federation become a
federation citizen just not become
starfly
this whole thing about those saying well
we granted her Asylum
it doesn't remove the fact that she
still can't be in Starfleet
it's not relevant the fact that she
requested Asylum isn't relevant to the
case and the Vulcan in this case
would have been jumping up and down go
whoa whoa whoa whoa very nice lovely
very clever
completely irrelevant it's not relevant
to the case at all that she has Asylum
this is my problem with Star Trek at the
moment
because they're doing a prequel their
hands are tied in lots of ways they
can't there's certain things they can't
do so they couldn't resolve this issue
in this episode they had to shoehorn
this excuse in to do the story and to
make the you know agenda stuff they
wanted to talk about which is Star Trek
at its best when it's a bit woke
but then they do it in a way that
doesn't make sense and they're guilty of
this over and over and over again and
the way around it don't do prequels
don't try to tell the same story again
strange new worlds is brilliant and I'm
really enjoying it but I really wish
they put captain pike
oh Anson Mount on a Starship in more you
know in like a Picard time frame where
they could actually do stories where
they don't have one hand type behind
their back because of all the other
stories that followed it but like at
least they're trying to stick to Canon
now I do feel like if this was early
Discovery they'd have just gone yeah
we'll just ignore it
just pretend that um you know it doesn't
matter so at least they are trying to
follow Cannon it's just maddening
that all the way through the end of that
episode I'm feeling like it's ruined
because
like I say they shoehorn in this excuse
that is irrelevant and doesn't really
make sense
the the solicitor thing is a round of
applause at the End by the crew and I'm
like yeah right they've got number one
back brilliant but
that wasn't a legal argument
at least with like the Bashir episode
there was a legal argument and it made
sense
and they were able to resolve the
augment stuff to some level
this actually
is an irrelevant episode in some ways
because it didn't do anything
other than number one's back and she's
got Asylum
irrelevant guys I'd love to know what
you think about arastroper Aspera
episode though because I actually think
it's a much better episode than the
first episode I didn't enjoy the first
episode I thought it was a bit silly I
was like she's a bit boring
um but um I thought this episode was
much much better
but what do you think get into the
comments and tell me if you are new to
the channel like subscribe do all those
things and um I'll see you next time
[Music]